two weeks ago a group of masked men
entered the all creation Family Church
in Ferguson Missouri during Sunday
service
Pastor marquelo Futrell a former police
officer noticed that men were carrying
guns in their waistbands
but he kept preaching and secretly told
his director to lock all the doors and
call the police
then the pastor approached the mem
bers
I just
saw the church and decided to come talk
to me
let's praise God for them coming
I said praise God that God sent them in
here
now the pastor wanted to keep his
congregation calm but at the same time
he wanted the men to know he was on to
them
don't you play with me I still got a cop
anointing and I still know what's going
on and I still know what's about to
happen God's about to change the plot of
the enemy lift your voice and shout unto
God for what he's about to do
now what happened next is stunning
will you guys permit me to pray for
y'all
can I pray for y'all
do you mind if I pray for you you mind
if I pray for you can I pray for you to
me and can I pray for you
they said I can pray for him come on
brother let's pray for him pray on the
unction of the Holy Ghost
s bowing their heads in Silence the
gunman sat as the entire congregation
sang and yes prayed
see that wasn't so bad brothers thank
y'all for letting us pray for you
and we're thankful that for whatever
reason the Lord that y'all come here I
just believe that you all will never be
the same again
[Applause]
come on if you believe they'll never be
the same again clap your hands and give
God praise
[Music]
joining me now is that pastor Pastor
marquelo Futrell from all creation
Family Church Pastor I I don't know how
you kept your cool but how long were the
gunmen there
I would say they were there for
approximately 20 minutes
I what happened with these suspects was
this an isolated incident or has this
happened to you before I mean no no it's
never happened they came into church we
believe that they were up to no good uh
I just had that instinct and I just
started maneuvering while trying to
conduct service to keep the the people
uh calm and uh
eventually we found out later that one
of those guys actually dropped his gun
on the ground before I approached them
to even pray for them and that's when
the police was alerted and then we found
out later that they were uh wanted in
connection with two robberies uh for
convenience stores
so they were coming presumably to like
Rob all of you during service I mean
what was their what was the goal here
that's that's what we believe we believe
that they were intending to uh Rob us do
some harm um but uh we believe God is
the greatest power and we cannot be
defeated and so uh I I had those
instincts I engaged them and uh we
prayed for him and uh they knew that
they were being recorded and so I had my
media team put the cameras on them
knowing that possibly the police was on
the way and we found out later when one
of the guys lifted his hands uh that the
tattoo in his hand uh was actually one
of the guys that had just hours before
committed a robbery at a convenience
store
what was the reaction among um the
congregants uh there for Sunday Services
when they realized what had happened
they were thankful to God they were
thankful uh to me and our team uh for
protection and just me navigating
through that process a lot of people
didn't know really what was going on uh
mini did and we had our children's
ministry on lockdown and so uh many of
the congregants was just thankful that I
was able to navigate them uh through
that process with the help of the Holy
Spirit the Holy Ghost wow well we're
looking at the video where
um some of the assailants a few of the
assailants are were bowing their head
and there's another powerful moment from
that service that I want everyone to
watch tonight
I just told her the Lord say this is
what happens when you illegally trespass
that when the enemy comes in like a
flood the spirit of the Lord will lift
up a standard
the flood will never be greater than the
standard
Pastor um so you're a former law
enforcement and a pastor and you're a
great auditor on top of that I mean you
got three things going for you that most
people in that situation even with the
Holy Ghost might not be able to have
been uh that uh that smart in reaction
yes just being led by the Holy Spirit
well Pastor um I have a feeling people
are going to feel really secure going to
church with you next Sunday and thank
you so much for what you did and for
keeping your cool we really really
appreciate it amazing story hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else